we never
quit is my father I'm there move move
get inside the
cave well done Planet how to fight today
I swear I'm going to get my family Into
the
Bunker Eric welcome to the show it's
good to be here it's good to see you and
all the rest of the team today um one of
the things I want to I want to tell our
viewers is I don't want to look at
things and say it's the end of the world
number one because it's only the end if
you're lost for a Christian for somebody
who has committed and surrendered to
Jesus Christ he promised we're going to
live forever he's promised us I'm gonna
make this world brand new again so it's
not the end it's just the beginning good
point Hallelujah and you know what like
I think too when talking about the end
of the world you know you hear so much
about judgment and this is coming and
it's going to be this time of trouble
that nobody's ever experienced before I
mean that those are coming from the
words of Jesus right um but that's
really for the unbelievers right so
God's promising protection over those
that are really truly on his side and we
should look forward to the Judgment
because that means that this thing is
ending and we are going to live forever
Psalms chapter 91 and chapter 46 are
specifically for the days we're living
in so I I encouraged all of our viewers
really read those things read them out
loud read them to your family read them
to your children if you're you know
still single read those promises Psalm
chapter 91 and chapter 46 I love it
let's dive into this okay so you're
gonna have to forgive me because I'm G
I'm I'm going to probably go a little
bit quick I'll try not to go too fast
but the topic that we're going to be
looking at even at the doors it's it's
based on what we find in the gospel of
Matthew chapter 24 and Luke chap 21 so
we're going to base everything on what
Jesus said the signs are going to be of
his return
awesome this is Matthew 24: 30 and 31
Jesus said
immediately after the tribulation of
those days shall the sun be darkened and
the moon shall not give her light and
the Stars shall fall from Heaven and the
powers of the heavens shall be shaken I
want to pause there just for a
minute I know that we have seen some of
these signs 180 years ago 200 years ago
uh the you know the Lisbon earthquake
the the dark day the Moon turning to
blood but from Jesus's own words those
signs are going to be repeated again
just before he comes because Jesus said
immediately after the tribulation and
when you read the context in Matthew 24
he's talking about the time of trouble
such as has never been that hasn't
happened yet right so he says and the
Stars shall fall from Heaven and the
powers of the heavens shall be shaken
and then shall appear the sign of the
son of man in heaven and then shall all
the tribes all the nations of the earth
mourn and they shall see the son of man
coming in the Clouds Of Heaven with
power and great glory and then it says
he shall send his angels with a great
sound of a trumpet and his angel Shall
Gather together his elect his chosen
from the Four Winds from one end of
Heaven to the
other and then Jesus tells us now learn
a parable of the Fig Tree when its
branch is yet tender and it putteth
forth leaves you know that summer is
nigh so likewise ye and I always tell
people put your name into that verse
because God's speaking to you and I
individually you when you see these
things you shall know that it is near
even at the doors I love it because each
generation really if you really think
about it no matter when you've lived on
this planet we live about the same space
of time I mean since the anti-d deluvian
world right we've been shortened down to
about a 100 years if you're lucky it's
even been way less like that in the 18
heav hundreds and maybe even the Dark
Ages but but generally you have 80 to
100 years right now so really it is at
the door for all of us amen amen in
Revelation chapter 22 the Lord tells us
behold I come quickly and my reward is
with me to give to every man according
as his work shall be now I want to
interject something here in Revelation
it talks about I think it's chapter 20 I
believe it's chapter 20 it talks about I
saw a great white throne and it says I
saw books were opened and the Wicked the
dead were judged out of those things
that were written in the books according
to their work
but the Bible says we are Christ
workmanship or we are God's workmanship
we have been created in Christ Jesus
unto good works which he has before
ordained that he will walk in us so th
those that are lost are going to be
judged according to what they've done
those that are saved are going to be
judged according to what they've allowed
Christ to do in them and through them
now we call that righteousness by faith
amen that means his life is my life
because he says so that's right and that
means I yield to him you're claiming the
promise that Lord your life I get a
chance to put that Veil on so that when
God sees us and looks at us he sees his
son and what his son has done amen and
it and it's neat because
like it's easy to picture as a veil that
we put on but it's actually opening the
door and letting Jesus come in literally
he comes into us and lives his life
inside of us yeah just like we see
Hollywood stars and musicians get
possessed so that they can perform God's
like let me in and I will live your life
for you and with you that's true a lot
of these performers they cannot perform
I mean if the spirit that is inside of
them is removed from them they can't rap
they can't sing they can't do all these
things right so you think about that
that's a very interesting concept that
you know what Jesus is promising that if
we let him in he will perform those
things amen that he's claiming he's done
and he has done and you know it's
amazing because he tells us without me
you can do nothing and even as
Christians we get in our mind look you
tell give me the instructions I can do
this I'm a big boy yeah you know let go
of my hand Daddy I can do this by myself
and God Jesus never said that Jesus said
I do everything with my father it's my
father that's working in me in fact I do
nothing without him without him
amen I want to show um a video clip here
and this is probably about a 4 minute
video clip is if you need me to pause
just tell me um but we're going to look
at what news broadcast have said we are
seeing in our world right now this week
the United Nations world food program
warned that as a result of the Corona
virus the number of people facing food
crisis around the world could double to
265 million people for how the
developing world is fairing already
suffering ing in many places from the
effects of climate change and conflict
I'm joined by David Beasley executive
director of the world saying uh this
week to the United Nations uh to anybody
who will listen that as the world deals
with this terrible Health crisis at the
very same time there's another crisis
having to do with
food well before covid came on the scene
literally in the last 6 months I'd been
telling leaders around the world and
especially in Europe that we had a
perfect storm coming we literally were
going to see 2020 being the worst
humanitarian crisis year since World War
II because of Yemen and Syria and South
Sudan the deterioration of the Sahel
climate extremes you know Cyclones and
hurricanes Sudan Ethiopia DRC and you
just can't imagine all these things
together then desert Locust Came Upon
that and I'm like this is just terrible
and then Co we couldn't believe it and
so we were already calculating 135
million people around the world before
covid marching to the brink of
starvation and now with a new analysis
with Co we're looking at 260 million
people and I'm not talking about hungry
I'm talking about marching towards
starvation and that is a we're analyzing
out every country to make certain that
we're doing what we possibly can but you
got to remember while everybody's
focused on covid right now desert Locust
is just devastating Kenya in uh Somalia
and South Sudan and Ethiopia so we're
dealing with several different so-called
plagues at one time farmers in South
Sudan know it takes more than shouting
and sticks to ward off a plague of
locusts but the Corona virus crisis is
preventing the delivery of pesticides so
they're losing a war against hundreds of
billions of locusts swarming through
East Africa devouring crops and
livelihoods
want pause there just for a second wow
all right this is news and they're
talking about the word plagues right um
not just Devastation not problems but
they're using biblical terminology
interesting and it's amazing too because
we see Locust that was one of the
plagues that fell upon Egypt right and
we're going to get into that but it it's
it's shocking at what even over the last
eight months we have seen more disasters
natural disasters quote unquote than
we've ever seen in in the history of
mankind in the last 8 months and they're
escalating last year we had to feed 5
million people due to fighting and
flooding already in 2020 we've had
Locust invasions and now there is the
covid-19 pandemic which we predict could
almost double the people in acute hunger
by the end of 2020 across the world the
un's food agency says the world is on
the brink of a hunger pandemic
it predicts the famines of biblical
proportions within just a few months if
action isn't taken nine days after
Hurricane Harvey came aure we're still
struggling to fully comprehend its
aftermath at least 45 people are
confirmed dead as of this morning while
the economic toll is estimated in the
tens of billions Mark stman has been
there through it
all Harvey hit Texas with Old Testament
wrath a Deluge along the state's Gulf
Coast that dumped more than 4T of rain
people in southern P County loud noises
in the sky this past weekend literally
rocked their world guys what is going
on strange sounds are being heard around
the
world in Sweden this sure sounds like a
trumpet in Michigan another trumpet-like
sound
[Music]
people have been recording strange
noises like this one in Kiev for some
time
now videos filmed all over the world
have appeared on YouTube the first in
summer last
year but no one's really sure what
they're hearing a lot of us have heard
our parents and grandparents say we're
in our last days is the in actually near
meaning in of the world multiple videos
of horn sounds coming from the skies
around the world over the last few years
have gone viral leaving us wondering
what is going
on that's crazy man man that's crazy
it's like a Trum
multiple locations around the world one
after another in different years is it a
sign the end is near journalist and
religious leader Dr Ruth Allison sat
down to explore those theories
tonight now that is something I haven't
actually heard that's pretty interesting
it is and and you know hearing something
loud like this right like you know I've
seen videos where they've experiment
mented with Holograms and and things
that you know you you drone things that
that could easily fake a second coming
but audio has always been an issue audio
is like yes you can get the visual you
can get this Grand Sky looking thing
over a city maybe as far as you can see
but how do you get the audio to play for
that so that's kind of fascinating I
wonder if they've figured something out
or if there really is truly something
Supernatural happening one of the things
that it caught my attention when I first
saw this was they keep talking about
they sound like
trumpets in the Book of
Revelation the seven last plagues are
poured out upon the Earth upon people
that have not surrendered to Christ
people that have received the mark of
the beast the the the signature of the
Beast instead of the signature of
Christ before those seven last plagues
are poured out though Revelation talks
about the fact that God is going to send
judgments on the Earth but they are
judgments with mercy so they are they
are events that are happening in order
to wake people up so that they can
repent and turn to God before it's too
late but it it calls them trumpets and
there were seven trumpets um it's also
interesting because in the Old Testament
Hebrew
economy you had day of atonement day of
atonement was like the close of
probation every case was decided on day
of atonement you were either in for God
or you were out prior to the day of
atonement there was the Feast of
trumpets the trumpets were warnings to
say get ready time is almost over the
the chance to decide is almost over how
much time was in between the trumpet and
the actual day day if I no I think it
was 10 days I think I have to look I
know in Leviticus chapter 23 it 10 days
to reflect on what you've done in your
life yeah and I want to be careful
because I don't remember for sure it was
10 days but I think it was
yeah we can we can look okay but it's in
uh Leviticus chapter 23 it talks about
each one of those days okay but the
point was is that God sent a warning
before the the plagues fell okay God has
doing the same thing God will not allow
any person the devil to kill anybody
without him sending a warning and trying
to save them you know I think there's a
an interesting spiritual application to
this right The Art of War is through the
element of surprise yeah God is not at
war with us amen God is God is defending
his character against somebody that's
wanting to war to him who's springing
the stuff on you and doesn't want you to
know what these things are is the devil
God has always put his things out there
I do nothing unless I unless I tell the
uh prophets first right reveal it to the
prophets that's the way God works he
reveals to us you are not caught off
surprise you're caught off guard you are
not surprised that's the way the devil
Works yes yes I I just checked it was 10
days trumpets began on the first day of
the month of the seventh month and then
on the 10th day of the seventh month
that was one day the D it was this is
pretty interesting it is now I'm just
GNA introduce a question here that came
to my mind okay so the news is talking
and they're using biblical terminology
about these events and I was like wait a
minute okay like I'm 55 years old I
spent
years killing myself watching Hollywood
movies like you I mean I us wasted hours
I mean entire weekends I'd watch 10
movies in a weekend I'd go to the video
store and just binge watch just trash
foolishness yeah but it's like one of
the things I can remember that I watched
especially in the 80s and '90s and
2000s was movies that were quote
apocalyptic end of the world kind of
movies and I was like so the news is
using biblical terminology but why in
the world is Hollywood also showing
films depicting the end of the world
same thing the you know I think the
devil's playing both sides of the field
here and in the entertainment spectrum
they are putting this idea out there
especially like
2012 the we said the end of the world
was going to happen in 2012 eh nope just
kidding so what they're doing is by
putting this idea out there where they
freak you out but nothing happens freak
you out but nothing happens they'll end
end up basically disarming you it's
crying wolf yeah you've done it three
times four times I'm not going to
believe you this time that's what I
think is going on here I I agree I had a
random thought when you were saying you
know you used to spend a lot of time 20
hours plus on the weekends right I just
want our audience to consider this right
if I told you that inside of this book
right here would teach you exactly what
you needed to do to win the lottery okay
so in here is the answers to win the
lottery in fact if you study this thing
and you put some time into it I mean you
everyone can win the lottery and you can
all win a billion dollars right how how
how many people would study this thing
and people would do it for a year I mean
they would do it every single day for
hours a day if you thought that that's
what you were going to get out of here
is I'm going to I'm going to definitely
win the lottery you are going to win the
lottery if if you get eternal life
eternal life this book gives us so much
valuable information for this time yet
very few people pick it up and read it
it's amazing because God promised it
it's not like okay you got to figure
this out God is like just surrender to
me I guarantee you you will be with me
in heaven he writes people often ask why
does he write in such like Parables and
code and like I can't understand it okay
so so he writes like that so that people
aren't lazy if you just if you just said
give me what do I got to do to get
eternal life right that's lazy it's
about a relationship with God so you
know what God does he goes I'm going to
give you the tools I'm going to tell you
how to do it I'm going to write the
thing in code and then I'm going to give
you the decoder the Holy Spirit he's
going to piece that whole thing together
God would not leave us to random but he
does that for a reason so that people
aren't lazily going there for selfish
reasons he wants a relationship with you
and those that truly seek Him will find
him amen and you know another thought
it's also really cool because God put
within every human being
a desire to understand Mysteries I mean
if it's a mystery if it's a secret if
it's hidden people want to figure it out
and God is like I know that about you
because I'm the one that put that in you
yeah so it's like he he's for us not
against us that's right uh just a a
quick highlight some of these movies are
older uh the one Deep Impact it was
about I think a comet or a huge asteroid
that was going to hit the earth and it
was it was pretty scary what they did in
that film um then you had armag with
Bruce Willis again there was an asteroid
that was coming and and this is what is
startling Scotty in that movie they
developed the scientists figured out a
way they said we think if we send a
spaceship up there a rocket and we put
these Miners and these different
scientists on the asteroid we can either
deflect the asteroid from hitting the
Earth or we can explode the asteroid
before it hits here do you know that
NASA has done that over the last couple
of years NASA has sent up two to the
best of my memory two missions now to
deflect an asteroid just to see if we
impact an asteroid can we knock it off
its course and they're doing that
because they said we want to know this
for when the time comes that one is
coming for the Earth so a rock is coming
for the Earth very interesting that that
parallel that's happening right there
also happens in the Transformer movies a
rock that's coming to destroy Earth
right of course they're just trying to
stop Armageddon and that's literally
what they said we want to stop
Armageddon but but if you're a true
follower of God you want Armageddon to
happen why because we want to be done
with this sin thing we want to go to
heaven and not have this evil world that
that we are all subjected to ever exist
ever again I want to live in a perfect
world I look forward I want to see an
end to the suffering I want to see an
end to children being molested and
people being raped and people being
murdered and amen God is the same way
it's it's great geving him to see the
pain byproduct of putting these kind of
ideas out into the public is it makes
you fearful and and also psychologically
want to side with yeah we need to stop
this thing but in Revelation 20
specifically verses 7 through um down on
the line where it says Gog and Magog
gather themselves together for the
battle of the great day of God Almighty
and Satan is loosed from his prison and
he's going around trying to Rally
everybody against that City he's trying
to stop Armageddon that is the same
message as what is in that movie right
there that is literally linking you with
Satan's psychology yes yes um yeah I'm
Gonna Leave the other ones they're
they're different events but the the
question that came to my mind was okay
why is Hollywood doing this and I agree
with you what you talk about it's cry
wolf that there was something else that
my uncle years ago showed
me the great controversy has been
between Christ and Satan when I say
great controversy it's it's a dispute
yeah it's a conflict but it's also a
dispute a controversy not just a fight
but there's a
controversy two things being said that
are opposing to each other right which
one of them has to be true and one of
them has to be a lie so how do we
display that in Revelation 12 it talks
about this it says there was war in
heaven Mel and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon fought in his
angels and prevailed not praise God Amen
neither was their place found anymore in
heaven and it says the Great Dragon was
cast out that old serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceiveth the
whole world he was cast out into the
Earth and his angels and the word angels
in Greek as Messengers were cast out
with him this is what my uncle showed me
he said Eric he said there's rules to
war even even now today I mean like the
UN they they will tell people look
you're not abiding by the rules that's
against you know international law for
you to do that in Warfare and you're
like that's kind of crazy to think about
hey there's rules to the war you can't
just kill civilians like you can't just
run into even if they're on the opposite
side right there's a lot of people that
did that in Vietnam and you know got in
a lot of trouble when they came home
went and fought for their country but
did Evil things over there they come
home and you get Court Marshal I know so
this is one of the rules r that God made
to this conflict because the conflict is
between Jesus and Satan that's right
Satan never even thought for a split
second I'm going to get back up there
and get past God the father right which
is a wild concept right there like that
he's literally like he he's the closest
to the go the the godhead right so he
should understand the Dynamics of the
godhead the most yet he was literally
like I don't want this one but I'll I'll
listen to you God but not that one I
know I know this is one of the rules
that God has showed us in his word
surely the Lord God will do nothing
except he revealeth his secret unto his
servants the prophets amen so God says
I'm going to do something but I'm going
to tell you beforehand so you can be
prepared that's right no element of
surprise and you know what sad is people
that don't know Jesus they'll say that's
not fair God didn't tell us and God is
like it it's been living it's been
sitting in your bedroom on the the
dresser for the last 10 years I've had
it there I would have shown you right
that's how God can say every tongue will
profess every knee will bow why because
if you were to see the history of your
life unfold in front of you and and if
God were to really reveal to your mind
every opportunity that you held your
hand up and said nope I don't want you
God you would realize that God didn't
spare the best of Heaven to try and save
you and he did that for all of us amen
amen the weird thing is Satan has to
play other rules period Satan he has to
obey God even today yeah he has to play
by the same rules so God says if you're
going to do something you have to reveal
it and Satan says I am God speaks to us
through his word Satan speaks to us
through hwood the music industry and
many of the popular authors that are
under his influence I totally 100% agree
with you this is exactly what is going
on but I also think that because Satan
can do nothing outside of the realm of
the way that God has designed him all
he's done is pervert it God designed him
to talk about God to tell others what
God is like and so he is talking about
God only he's pointing the camera back
at himself he is pointing the accusation
finger at God but he's still talking
about God you know what I mean like he's
still if he really didn't care about God
and he really wanted to be this other
thing why doesn't he go off in the
corner of the internet or corner of the
the the universe and do something
totally different why are you mimicking
the things of God because you were
programmed to tell others about God Amen
so here he is just perverting that and
then taking it on for himself well you
see that's what he's done through the
movies it's like he's telling things but
he's mixing truth and lies
yeah in Mark chapter 13 which is a
parallel uh chapter to Matthew 24 and
Luke 21 Mark tells Us in those days
shall be afflictions such as was not
from the beginning of the creation which
God created unto this time neither shall
be and except that the Lord had
shortened those days no flesh should be
saved but for the elect sake that means
those that God has chosen whom he has
chosen God has shortened those
days and then if any man shall say unto
you Lo here is Christ or Lo he is there
Jesus tells us believe him not for false
Christ and false prophet shall arise and
show signs and wonders to seduce if it
were possible even the elect but take
heed for behold I have for told you all
things Jesus is like there's going to be
people that are going to come that if it
were possible they will deceive the very
elect and not just human beings human
beings that are possessed by evil
spirits since we're kind of talking a
little bit about Hollywood here too and
the messages that they're putting out I
think this is another reason why it's
dangerous when you see all these um
savior types yes there's savior types
without being a a type of our savior you
know what I mean they're saving you from
something that's coming in the sky but
really has nothing to do with your your
morality so for example like in in the
Transformer series Optimus Prime is
trying to save earth right well would we
all say hey it's a good idea to save
humans on Earth yes right but it has
nothing to do with what you're acting
like or anything like that he's you know
Optimist Prime is not saying you should
be morally good you shouldn't kill
people you shouldn't steal from people
you shouldn't do any of that right he
says nothing about your morality he's
like a savior but he has the character
of the
devil we live in solemn times time is
short begin your relationship with Jesus
today amen pick up your Bible read it
ask God to reveal himself to you and
trust me if you seek him with all of
your heart you will find him I guarantee
it or your money back amen amen all
right we love you guys God bless you
[Music]